any kid who grew up in the 1980s
probably remembers the popular sitcom
punky brewster
from its challenger episode to the fact
that the show's namesake was an actual
person
here's everything you don't know about
the happy-go-lucky series
sole moon fry had appeared in a couple
of made-for-tv movies and a handful of
television episodes when she landed the
role of plucky punky brewster
despite being a relative newcomer to
show business when the series debuted in
1984
eight-year-old fry did boast some
meaningful connections to punky
brewster's creator
her older half-brother mino palucci was
a successful child actor
appearing on the tv version of the bad
news bears voyagers and as abused child
toby on a very special episode of silver
spoons
as it turned out silver spoons was
developed by david w duclon who was also
the creator of punky brewster
despite this helpful link to the show
source fry still had to endure
a very competitive audition process
producers put out a casting call far and
wide and only decided that fry was the
right actor for the part
after considering around 3 000 other
candidates among those fry defeated was
melissa joan hart who'd later star as
the similarly quirky sabrina on sabrina
the teenage witch
funnily enough fry ended up on that show
as well playing sabrina's friend roxy
king
the deep and deliberately voiced george
gaines had been a hard-working character
actor since the early 1960s he'd landed
small parts on dozens of episodes of tv
shows including hogan's heroes colombo
and hawaii 5-0
however gaines didn't really explode
into the public consciousness until 1984
thanks to back-to-back breakout roles as
commandant eric lassard in police
academy
and as punky's reluctant adoptive parent
henry on punky brewster
however gaines wasn't immediately in
contention to land that sitcom dad role
seasoned television actor fred gwynne
was gunning for the part as well which
would have marked his third successful
sitcom following card 54
where are you and the monsters in which
he starred as the goofy hermann munster
i'm every inch gentleman in fact
several gentlemen gwen was eager to be
associated with a role besides that of a
monster from a
20 year old novelty sitcom he attended
his punky brewster audition dressed in a
white suit with a fresh haircut hoping
to look as little like herman munster as
possible
but then sole moon fry arrived to read
lines with gwen and innocently asked
aren't you herman munster gwen was so
disappointed he botched his audition
did you say utes yeah two utes
what is a ute punky brewster ranks as
one of the most memorable names in tv
history
it fits the character tremendously with
her free-thinking wardrobe choices and
attitude to the point that one would
think the name was made up by the show's
writers but
in fact the name was taken from an
actual person nbc entertainment
president brandon tartikoff commissioned
the show punky brewster
suggesting the concept to creator david
w duclon with the caveat that the main
character be named punky brewster
as a child tartikov attended
lawrenceville school in exclusive boys
only academy where he met the daughter
of a teacher whose name was adorably
punky brewster punky was
actually a nickname the young woman's
real first name was payton when punky
brewster was in production in 1984
tartikov had nbc's lawyers find the real
punky
now married and going by peyton rutledge
to get her approval and pay her for the
right to use her name she gave it
and also agreed to film a cameo what's
your name
punky brewster punky brewster
strange name in the mid-1980s nbc was
enjoying a long running and very
lucrative deal that allowed them to run
nfl games on sunday afternoons
sometimes those football games ran long
exceeding the allocated time slot
and thus intruding upon the network's
pre-scheduled primetime television block
nbc wasn't going to cut away from a
hotly contested football game in favor
of whatever sitcom or scripted drama was
supposed to start at 7 p.m so whatever
show had that slot was bound to
experience some interference during the
fall and winter months
nbc anticipated this fate befalling
punky brewster set to debut in september
1984
to help ensure that punky brewster would
find a foothold with young viewers and
not be gobbled up by football
nbc announced a unique format tweak for
the show before it even debuted
of the initial 13 episodes of punky
brewster ordered three would be
collapsible
meaning they could be broken down into
two standalone 15 minute episodes
that way if football ran long nbc could
still air an episode of punky brewster
that millions of kids had made an
appointment to watch
and also ensure its 8 pm hit knight
rider could start on time
15 minute shows hadn't been part of the
nighttime tv landscape since the 1960s
when the networks produced 15 minute
primetime newscasts but punky brewster
brought the format back
punky brewster's biggest supporter and
constant partner in mischief
is her close friend cherry johnson who
lives in the same building as punky's
foster father henry
the character of cherry johnson was
played by a young actor also named
cherry johnson and that wasn't a
coincidence punky brewster's creator
david w duclon
just happened to be johnson's uncle
johnson told mental floss he created the
show but not for me to have a job he
just thought he'd use my name and that
i'd be thrilled
duclon was only vaguely aware that his
niece had acting aspirations of which
she wasn't quite convinced herself
on the set of duklan's other 80s show
silver spoons johnson told parlay that
she watched ricky schroeder perform and
told duclon that she could do the same
when punky brewster entered production
and johnson learned that duklan had
named a character after her johnson
pushed to play the role as johnson later
recalled duklan wanted a quote
real actress after johnson auditioned
seven times however nbc told declon to
cast her
oh cherish i must have a green thumb
i sure have grown a pretty little flower
thanks grandma on january 28
1986 nasa launched the space shuttle
challenger this was almost a routine
occurrence as this would be the tenth
time challenger had gone into space in
three years
but this time was indeed different high
school teacher kristen mcauliffe was one
of seven challenger crew members
set to become the first american
civilian to visit space
because of the historical importance and
educational connection countless
classrooms around the country tuned in
to watch the challenger launch live
tragically a little over a minute after
liftoff the space shuttle exploded
killing all seven crew members it's
impossible to say how many kids watching
the moment on tv were traumatized but
the fact that it became a shocking
generational milestone is beyond
question
one of those kids left sad and troubled
by the event was a fictional one
tv's punky brewster the character
repeatedly affirms her desire to be an
astronaut when she grows up so david w
duclon wrote an episode in which the
character processes the challenger
disaster
according to the los angeles times
duclon also wanted to help kid viewers
manage their feelings and to not give up
on their dreams of being astronauts
someday
that encouragement is explicitly
delivered to punky in the episode by
special guest star buzz aldrin
the second man to walk on the moon punky
brewster received numerous letters from
young viewers who would write
suggestions on what they wanted to see
punky do
as show producer rick hawkins told
mental flaws this inspired david w
duclon to have an official contest in
which he asked kids to send in their
punky brewster ideas in the hopes of
having it become an actual episode
a seven-year-old punky brewster fan
named jeremy reems sent in the winning
entry which suggested punky should show
kids how to use cpr to save a life
show writers ran with that concocting
the 1986 episode cherry lifesaver
wherein punky's best friend cherry gets
trapped in a junked fridge while playing
hawkins told the outlet that idea came
out of research we had done where we
learned an alarming number of kids had
suffocated in an old fridge or freezer
by the 80s fridges had to be openable
from the inside but as hawkins told
mental floss
in low economic neighborhoods the old
fridges were being tossed out in vacant
lots
cherry nearly dies in that fridge only
for punky to save her with cpr
punky brewster was popular enough that
nbc sought to expand their spunky
fashion forward star's tv empire in the
fall of 1985 a year after punky brewster
debuted
nbc's saturday morning lineup welcomed a
new cartoon
also called punky brewster although it
was sometimes referred to as its punky
brewster to differentiate it from its
live-action counterpart
while the sitcom is about an orphan
living with a sometimes stodgy old man
the animated series is a bizarre
fantastical adventure with the
characters of punky brewster added in
the animated show also featured a cute
magical gopher-like creature
named glomer who comes from a city at
the end of the rainbow and gets lost in
the real world
only to meet punky and her friends this
punky brewster lasted for two strange
whimsical seasons
not as successful a spin-off was fenster
hall nbc aired the pilot as an episode
of punky brewster in march 1985 without
ordering a full series
such a series would have explored the
day-to-day happenings of a children's
shelter which briefly served as a
temporary home to punky herself
in early episodes of punky brewster
believe it or not this spin-off series
would have been a comedy
despite its impact with young viewers
punky brewster was not a breakout
ratings hit
in the 1984-85 season it ranked 69th out
of 77 shows in terms of viewership and
fell to 76th
in season 2. this was bad news for punky
brewster fans and
nbc cancelled it in 1986. there was good
news however the network
sold it to a television syndicate
several hundred non-network-affiliated
tv stations in the u.s
needed programming and many relied on
modestly budgeted scripted productions
sold to them by distributors
joining the ranks of programs of dubious
quality like she's the sheriff small
wonder and mama's family were the third
and fourth seasons of punky brewster
after a post-nbc hiatus of a year and a
half these seasons aired on independent
stations around the country in late 1987
and early 1988.
these 44 episodes nearly didn't get
produced at all
in a contract dispute sole moon fry
didn't report for work when it came time
to shoot the first episodes for
syndicator columbia pictures television
the company then threatened fry
10 years old at the time with an 80
million lawsuit if she continued to hold
out
punky brewster ended a four-year
88-episode run in the spring of 1988
with its animated saturday morning
spin-off wrapping up a year earlier
and yet the franchise hasn't remained
dormant in 2014 comics publisher
lionforge's roar imprint added a digital
only punky brewster book series to its
line of nostalgia stirring adaptations
of 80s titles like airwolf knight rider
and saved by the bell the comic was a
collaboration between teen titans writer
joelle selner and artist leslie vamos
eventually collected and published as
punky power
the comic serves as a prequel to the
1980s series focusing on a homeless
punky brewster as she wanders the city
looking for a place to live
in january 2020 nbc universal announced
that a new punky brewster series was in
the works
set to debut in 2021 on the peacock
streaming service so lei moon fry
returns as the title character
now a single mother of three who is
still friends with cherry and still
occasionally wears two mismatched
shoes heartwarmingly she befriends a
girl in foster care who reminds her of
her old self
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one